was the most about bitcoins can choose
the pizza flower that's up to you
some of these flowers may never go home
at that rate it's my pleasure to
introduce our speaker for the evening
Charles Payne is the executive officer
and principal analyst of Wall Street
strategies incorporated which he founded
in 1991 his passion for the stock market
began when he was 14 years old and he
told his mother that one day he would
work on Wall Street today his company
provides information to over a hundred
and twenty thousand registered
subscribers in more than 60 countries as
well as several of the largest banks and
brokerage firms Charles oversees a team
of stock analysts who cover specific
industry groups in addition to
monitoring the entire market and
individual sectors on his own Charles is
the host of making money with Charles
Payne on the Fox Business Network he
often is featured on Barney and Company
and Cavuto on business his articles
having appeared in in many journals
including Wall Street Journal the New
York Times and Reuters he is the author
of the book act fast be smart and get
rich speaking to us on the subject of
cronyism which we have discussed quite a
bit at this conference please welcome
Charles Payne
good afternoon that was a very nice
introduction I appreciate it it's great
to be here
I almost almost didn't make it anybody
hear about the Ebola doctor in New York
well as it turns out I've got a cousin
who has I think it's munchausen syndrome
she is always sick she always wants
someone to feel sorry for I always get
these texts from her I'm in the hospital
again homeboy
can't you know I need a few dollars now
her husband they both work finally I
gave her money today this morning before
I left why she is the neighbor of the
ebola doctor you cannot make this up
oh god I'm like Stephanie she is his
neighbor when he sits on his sofa she
hears it now I will tell you what she
has told me so far in some of the
pictures that she sent pretty pretty
disturbing
there is no protocol if there is it
needs a lot of work so even before I got
on the plane she sent me a picture of
his door
nothing sealed nothing covered it was
it's pretty pretty pretty worrisome so
let's pray that Ebola really is hard to
get that's all I can tell you i we can
let the officials take a victory lap if
no one gets it but it won't be because a
protocol in the meantime I'm out a
thousand bucks to Stephanie and the
actually I grew up two blocks from
theirs 146th Street and Broadway so the
good news is she's gonna have a hard
time topping in bowling right I need
money for what no I can't give it to you
for a flat tire you got to come up with
something better than Ebola so maybe
when the Martians invade you heard about
the Martians
they're my building uh okay come on all
right well I appreciate being here I
have my own business stock market
research it's something I really love
have a passion for over the years
started doing a lot of television became
a contributor with Fox in 2004 and for
the last four months I've had my own
show called making money with Charles
Payne so please watch it I think a very
binding room watches it will double the
audience thank you very much by the way
my stock last night's Blanc was up four
bucks today come on guys so let's talk
about this crony capitalism two weeks
ago the Ebola scare was at its peak
right Isis was moving in on a kabbani
circling the Baghdad Airport and all the
powers that be they had some other
things on their minds you know they had
they say you know let's have a war game
and the war game players included the UK
the Chancellor of the Exchequer George
Osborne Jack Lew Janet Yellen her UK
counterpart Mark Carney and you know
it's interesting because anybody
familiar with the Doomsday Clock you
know the old clock it strikes midnight
and and mankind has sort of killed
itself the Doomsday Clock has certainly
moved closer toward midnight over the
last few months or so so you figured
okay these guys are gonna have this war
game it might be an appropriate time for
that
unfortunately what they were preparing
for was the next bank bailout and some
people actually think they were
preparing for a bank bail in what a bail
in is in case you're not sure is when
they take your money to save the bank
instead of printing up some fresh cash
either way it seemed like a pretty odd
time to have that sort of event but
don't worry the Department of Defense
also was on the job they were explaining
how climate change is the greatest
threat to our nation and should be the
top priority of our military I can tell
you right now there's a lot that can be
said for crony capitalism but the one
thing you can never say it's not small
potatoes they go for the big
don't thing alright so government so far
in America they've lassoed in the banks
the health care system student loans
champing at the bit to control the
entire energy patch and you know we talk
a lot particularly in the media and
amongst ourselves about the different
isms because it's you know we're really
sensitive society so there's sexism
there's right racism there's nepotism
elitism anyone in New York understands
that one but none of these actually cost
us money and at the same time strip away
our rights right strip away our our
opportunities that truly should be
inherent in a free-market society and
that's why crony capitalism which is an
oxymoron is one of the most dangerous
things going on in this country at this
very moment the textbook definition
crony capitalism a term describing an
economy in which success in business
depends on a close relationship between
business people and government officials
it may be exhibited by favoritism in a
distribution of legal permits government
grants special tax breaks or other forms
or state interventionism now the problem
with with this particular definition is
not just because it's about basic
business success or just the unlimited
greed of the players involved but it's
their ability to build moats around
these industries and to stop the free
market from working the start-stop
entrepreneurs from getting involved to
stop mid-sized businesses from becoming
larger businesses unless they learn how
to play the game these days in America
our own brand of crony capitalism
starting to resemble things that have
gone on in Europe for a long time in
other nations you know a couple years
ago we talked about the Arab Spring make
no mistake a large part of that was
crony capitalism the center point was
Tunisia where the guy set himself on
fire after being denied a business
permit and having his ox Co his cart of
goods turned over the government there
about 60 to 70% of industry so in this
country right now we're a long way from
when Tocqueville and a whole lot of
others in that era came and they visited
and they saw this young startup
wonderful nation but a brash upstart
write every word Tocqueville wind
everybody he met thought they could be
successful he can comprehend this what
do you mean in Europe you had to either
be part of the royal family or someone
very connected everyone then thought
they can control their own destinies and
their own fortunes so we fast forward to
these days and now well our own system
we've got this gargantuan government
with uncontrollable spending supported
by wealthy benefactors political allies
and it's all about them taking larger
and larger chunks of the action in some
respects people say it's sort of like
socialism but it's even closer in some
ways to the fascism that Mussolini saw
or tried to have where hey you can have
free markets as long as it's layer over
by government and okay I know it's
logical and it's oxymoronic but that's
exactly what they were going for and in
many respects it feels like that's where
we're heading or where we're going right
now so you know it's not really about
capitalism in some ways though it's
because it's in its Sidious this
relationship that we're talking about
but let's talk about capitalism for a
moment and what makes it so great and so
unique to free markets first and
foremost I think is risk-taking you know
so few people in our country these that
this day are they are they willing to
take risk
they are so intimidated they are so
afraid a lot of this comes from a lack
of belief in the system anymore
obviously and legitimately a lot of it
become it's because of a lack and
leadership you know we're like a
rudderless ship people are afraid to put
their chips in because no one's looking
out for them innovation an extraordinary
part of the free markets creation
creativity
refinements you know this week in the
stock market a whole lot of companies
reported their earnings so what were the
companies that did not do very well
McDonald's their cheeseburger hasn't
changed a lot in the last thirty years
right if you were in a time capsule
forty years ago in the last thing you
had was a cheeseburger from McDonald's
and you came out today like whoa things
haven't changed that much of course if
you go to like steak shack or in-and-out
burger or the five guys or one of these
other places that capita McDonald's it's
the same burger I had forty years ago
coca-cola not much has changed except
tastes and people in America
particularly you know moving away from
sodas IBM now in their defense it's hard
to reinvent yourself of your 100 year
old company but they've got to do it and
I you know they have not been able to do
it all of these companies very old
they've been successful in a passive
reinvention but refinements competition
it's all about competition this whole
thing that we're doing now with our kids
nobody fells nobody loses it's just so
it's just nuts it's absolutely crazy you
know the but that's one of the key
components of free markets and
capitalism in my mind but for me
probably the most important component of
them all is failure the ability to fail
and that's closely related to pain if
you think about where we are right now
as a nation the biggest thing you can do
for people is to say I will ease soothe
or even remove your pain so whether it's
psychological pain emotional pain even
economic pain why do you think
politicians buy votes if you can ease
our pain hey things have gone wild hey
throw a trillion dollar stimulus at it
will gets it fixed up forget about where
the money came from a who you have to
pay it back to later if I can ease that
pain right now you'll vote for me right
of course protecting businesses though
from failure that is the worst thing
absolutely worst thing possible Japan's
two decade-long failure largely a result
of them propping up failed businesses
for a long long time businesses suffer
employees suffer a consumers suffer the
society suffers and of course when you
prop them up with taxpayer money
everybody in this room suffers I think
it actually not only erodes society I
think it should be criminal to be quite
frank with you it's gone too far now
let's talk about the innovation thing a
little bit more walling up innovation in
eighteen twenty China had the greatest
economy in the world they had had the
greatest economy in the world for a long
time if you ever looked at a long chart
of global wealth even though we'll
probably end up getting back to this
point where China India more than 50% of
it it won't be the first time
but what China had done as they were so
far ahead of everyone else they'd had
decided to wall themselves up and once
they walled themselves up the emperor
put into place a crony system and the
thing is it worked into the British
arrived now the Emperor was still pretty
puffed up eight said listen you know
we're more advanced than everyone else
you know one thing led to another and
when the British unleashed their fury of
their ships and they took down the
Chinese like that it was sort of ironic
because you know obviously a big part of
the warfare was the same gunpowder that
it had started in China but he volved in
the rest of the world also the British
had been at war with just about
everybody else in Europe and they
learned how to fight better it was
competition they learned tactics they
learned techniques they learned weapon
tree china in the meantime set on its
laurels rome set on its laurels to the
point where they had to pay mercenaries
how do you conquer the world and then
you have to pay mercenaries you rest on
your laurels you put it in neutral
America we put it in neutral in 1970s
someone said the Japanese
he's gonna sell cars we laughed are you
kidding me a Datsun are you kidding me
no problem we'll just fight with the
unions over the spoils was no big deal
we got it now you know I think the
framers knew were smart enough to know
that government had the ability to
create monopolies had the ability to
delve into crony capitalism and as far
as they went that I know or could see it
was being smart enough to have a patent
system and a copyright system but other
than that a free society a free market
beginning of course with speech religion
but also a marketplace voluntary
exchange between buyers and sellers
agreed-upon prices and that's it that's
how you get it that's a free market and
it really worked out until the
government started to get more and more
in the middle of these transactions so
at some point it makes not it doesn't
make for the best prices and we are not
necessarily acting in our own interest
we're being nuts and okay so you'll give
me $2,000 if I get a solar panel and
you'll do this for me and yeah you know
you can push you can manipulate but it's
not a free market the opposite of
limited government is the kind of
government whose the one we have now
insatiable appetite just requires lots
of money lots of connections the ability
to manipulate or being part of every
single transaction possible and for me I
talked a lot about the fact that in my
mind sometimes when I think big
government big business is not unlike
the relationship of the coyote and a
badger anybody familiar with this
relationship folklore started talking
about this the American Indians Navajos
the Chinook and they noticed this first
it was an unusual appearing that they
kind of recognized that both the coyote
and a badger dying on small little
things animals prairie dogs squirrels
sort of like in crony capitalism when
big businesses and government dine on
our money and an interesting thing is
the coyote which by the way is the Aztec
word for trickster the coyote had its
gifts and the Badger had its gift so
often a coyote
would chase the small prey but then the
prey would go into the ground that's
when a badger with its sharp claws would
go in and get the prey out an amazing
thing in fact not too long ago
researchers watch this in the wild and
they said anytime that coyotes hunted
with badgers their take went up 30% and
the Badgers didn't do too bad either so
my only thing is right now I'm not sure
and crony capitalism who's the coyote
who's the badger okay I'm thinking the
government might be the coyote but I'm
just not sure because they have sharp
claws too just like the Badgers and the
big winners let's talk about the big
winners and crony capitalism it's so
many to pick from I want to start there
with Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac because
they're in the news again they are not
going away depression-era agencies and
of course they help to allow for the
facilitation and the financing of
mortgages banks can make more loans they
had a place to you know lay those off
but of course the whole thing went off
the rails when they started accepting
higher risk loans or mortgages that were
not in their original charter and then
of course George HW Bush when he signed
into Housing and Community Development
Act of 1992 we had already seen a
political ization of Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac it had already started
started with the Community Reinvestment
Act a long time before that but we're
talking now where we started that hockey
stick ramp you know a lot of people know
about the hockey stick thing with the
sort of putting in on steroids the
democratically controlled Congress
pushed it passed it the bowl we have to
meet affordable housing goals of course
who set those goals the Department of
Housing kerbin development now initially
they said okay we want 30% of growth and
low income loans to be financed here so
you know that they really didn't take
them before they didn't really want to
bother with that it was too high-risk
these were government's upon certain
agencies after all well by 2007 55% of
their mortgages were these low-income
extraordinarily high risk loans and we
know that that was the top of the market
and that was the powder keg and the
thing is like
so many of these government agencies
neither Republicans or Democrats are
really ever interested in curbing the
power that they have I mean think about
it's like executive order executive Fiat
President Obama is gonna use an
executive authority yeah but you're not
gonna do much to stop him because one
day you'll have the White House and
you'd like to use it as well I mean as
far as the White House is concerned -
when it comes to Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac what's one of the best things a
president on a staff could brag about
higher homeownership didn't matter what
risk was although you know it's
interesting this last election turned
all of the some of the old truisms
around right because President Obama had
lower homeownership lower wages lower
GDP and still got elected so I don't
know maybe we'll have a new paradigm but
as this Great Recession sort of fades a
little bit of recedes a little bit
there's gonna be a gigantic push again
on this housing thing and it's gonna be
a gigantic unimaginable amount of money
out there for big government it's gonna
be really limitless I think about this
when we bailed out Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac starting in 2008 Fannie Mae
got a hundred and sixteen billion
dollars Freddie Mac got 72 billion
dollars since then those loans have been
repaid now how do you repay those how do
you how did they come out of these holes
well you know the Federal Reserve has
been buying back quantitative easing
which has been in a financial media they
tell people the Fed is buying stocks
which is stupid that's not what they're
doing but what they are buying is what
they call agency back agency
mortgage-backed securities these are
generated by Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
it is the toxic stuff they wrap it up
and they sell it to the Fed for
make-believe money why is Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac all of a sudden turned into
money-making machines they've been able
to take all of this junk and put it into
a yuka mountain
wherever the Fed keeps this stuff all
right
and in the meantime they keep the good
stuff
Fanny has paid back 127 billion dollars
in Counting Freddie has paid back
88 billion dollars in countin counting
these stocks for a while was starting to
trade higher higher people were like hey
they paid their debt maybe they'll be
able to operate like independent
companies Congress said are you nuts
generating that kind of money never I
mean it's sort of like I've read the
story about Don King and when he would
hire his fighters he'd say hey come on
in I got a big fight for you need you to
sign a contract and he'd hand him a
piece of paper and just with a line at
the bottom of it and they said well
what's that he said that's the contract
they say there's only a line he said yes
sign it I'll fill the rest in later
don't worry about it okay yeah okay Don
I guess some that's what they did when
they bailed out Fannie and Freddie it
was just a line no terms no terms it's
gonna go on forever as long as you're
omitting money until they end up with
another gigantic bailout
then they'll figure it all out so
Wednesday this week the SEC they
approved what they're finally came up
with their a thing they called the risk
retention for banks it was voted the
vote was three to two now you guys
remember this thing when the president
was running and he talked about how
these bankers have to eat their own
cooking how dare them bundle up this
stuff and sell it to unsuspecting banks
hey listen it was a game of musical
chairs more than anything else but he
said he was gonna make sure they eat
their own cooking and this way it would
prevent them from you know packaging up
too much junky stuff dangerous stuff and
it would protect everybody especially
those unsophisticated investors I don't
know what unsophisticated investor ended
up with all that junk
the reason Bear Stearns got in trouble
and all these guys got in trouble is it
was a lot of sophisticated players
playing a very dangerous game in the
meantime though it did sound great to a
bloodthirsty public they wanted to
punish those nefarious bankers for
causing the housing bubble it wasn't
someone who lied in their application
you kidding me it wasn't someone who was
flipping houses and told his cousin's
hey this thing is easy it wasn't their
fault
it was the nefarious bankers so know
what we'll do next time around they
gotta buy this stuff they got
we're gonna make sure they keep a big
piece of it well five percent is not
necessarily the piece I thought that
they were talking about now two two
votes against it they were Republicans
they didn't think that that it was big
enough to deter any sort of shenanigans
that went on like last time or that it
was stopped a whole high-risk loan
business also there was nothing in their
provision to the to start the unwinding
of Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac so I mean
right now I think they sit on three
trillion three to four trillion dollars
and mortgages so now right before this
risk retention thing on Monday Fannie
and Freddie said okay you know what
we're gonna do we want to help society
out we'll start to buy these loans three
percent down so now we've got the risk
potential rules for banks only have to
keep 5% Fannie and Freddie saying hey
you know what have you got three percent
get a house sounds familiar right like I
said it's gonna be one heck of a party
for everybody who's connected these
connected players are going to make a
whole lot of money and the clock starts
ticking again so let's talk a little bit
about these players because maybe we
should look up to him in 2011 President
Obama announced with a whole lot of
fanfare his jobs council we're gonna put
together a jobs Council and we're gonna
jumpstart the economy I had a snow
blower where I was trying to jumpstart
for like four or five years like that
same thing it's just uh yeah every
winter I end up calling the same kid
yeah I can't get this thing working man
can you come over and shovel the yard
for me anyway jumpstart the economy
that's the famous phrase got a who's who
of industry got some union guys on there
some academics and I will admit that the
membership on this jobs council it's
like it should be the crony capitalism
Hall of Fame he's right about that let's
start with the leader Jeff ml GE he's
got a special spot just like Babe Ruth's
got a special spot in the Baseball Hall
of Fame he's got a special spot in a
crony capitalism Hall of Fame I mean few
companies take as much of taxpayer money
as general
treat federal subsidies alone around 400
million dollars 2010 their tax bill was
this much in fact we owe them three
billion dollars don't forget about the
export-import bank forget about a
billion dollars or so from there because
they need help to get business from
around the world so why not help them
out then Ken Chenault American Express
thinking all kinds of assortment of
subsidies and breaks and gifts from
taxpayers they actually had a real good
one
in November 2008 when American Express
was allowed to become a bank so that we
could give them a three point eight
billion dollar bailout how many people
ever go to the local American Express
Bank branch yeah Jim Owens caterpillar
hundreds of millions Exim Bank a lot of
government interference on trade deals
Ursula burns I mean listen she's got a
great story she started off as like an
intern or maybe the mailroom or
something in a Xerox and maybe maybe
that's why they thought she was the
right person to manage the electronic
benefits cards EBT which what's really
is a brilliant thing these EBT cards now
I could tell you when I grew up in my
neighborhood it was sort of odd because
we were all poor right everybody in my
neighborhood we were poor but and my
mother was sent me to the store with
food stamps
and one of my neighbors walked in as I
was at the register I would walk away I
don't I didn't want anybody to see me
with the food stamps it was a sort of
stigma even though I know they had him I
had him we all had him what the heck
what were we trying to hide but we still
had a little bit of pride so how do you
really grow the program to get the
stamps give him a card like a credit
card this thing has been amazing this
one abused almost 15 million people
everybody likes those EBT cards pull him
out anywhere
lots of transactions guess who's making
big-time money off of him Xerox JP
Morgan then is richard Parsons mr. Fixit
he was brought in at Citicorp to help
them survive that one of the biggest if
not the biggest Bank debacle of all time
and you know of course Citibank probably
though should orb richard Parsons and
crew I mean if you want to talk about
creativity you know they didn't have to
pay taxes for four years even after they
took by some estimates over two trillion
dollars in direct and indirect bailouts
from Americans in a Federal Reserve Jim
McNerney Boeing no one gets a bigger
slice of that Exim Bank than they did I
mean it's really remarkable you know
it's so funny because Boeing themselves
will tell you over the next 20 years the
demand for commercial aircraft around
the world it's just incredible I think
it's something like fourteen fifteen
thousand commercial airplanes for over
five trillion dollars do they really
need taxpayer money to induce extra help
it's it just it doesn't make sense
lewis hey next error energy this guy is
what I call the Latin Lover of crony
capitalism you see he was a he was a
big-time donor to John McCain but he
visited the White House in 2009 before
Michelle could even hang the curtains I
mean this guy was like he's like hey he
would come with you and leave at her I
mean whoever's got to catch it the power
and he's there with his checkbook well
it worked out pretty good for him
they own Florida plop our inline you've
gotten over two billion dollar in tax
taxpayer money he's really big and he's
clean energy bills you know desert
sunlight in California the the the
genesis solar project in California he's
got energy smart he's got Silver Springs
Network we're working on some
interesting things with the smart grid
that one day will be smart I don't think
in anybody's life time in his room and
that was started by a venture capitalist
from kleiner perkins John doar and if
that name sounds familiar yeah he was on
a jobs council
Matthew Rose of Burlington Northern of
course they benefit from an assortment
of government goodies and it's really
this one is a good good example I'm
going to talk in a minute about how this
is a great example of how these
incestuous relationships can last
forever
now remember Burlington now
by Warren Buffett been able to really
really play a great role in stopping the
Keystone pipeline because they are
making so so much money most of these
rails are closed closed this week at
all-time highs now remember for a large
chunk of the business was coal and when
that went down these they were in
trouble but what they're making from
frac sand and from oil you know I'd say
more power to them I've got people who
own some of these stocks but it is
largely stopping competition and in the
most unfair of ways don't forget dick
Parsons and penny pritzker I like those
names right sounds like a 1950s comic
book you know dick Parsons and penny
Pritzker they braked in a lot of money
on the solar scene and like I said this
whole thing it's becoming more more
American like his apple pie in 1864
Congress created the North Pacific rail
company they gifted them with 40 million
acres of land 2% of the entire
contiguous United States
and since then it's just been a amazing
they've spun off Burlington Northern
Weyerhaeuser potlatch Boise Cascade so
you know this whole thing is nuts the
president's jobs Council by the way they
met four times in two years they went a
whole year span without meeting and it
finally they just put it to bed I mean
it was a it was a farce from the very
beginning but it was an amazing fun
thing I guess while it lasted this stuff
also of course goes on on a local level
as well subsidies grants and the guys
often of helping the little guy small
people we want to help them out you know
a Monday to Department of Labor issued a
hundred and seventy million dollars to a
bunch of organizations that are going to
help people learn job skills I looked
through this list I don't think they're
gonna help anyone they're all phony
acorn type organizations they're not
gonna help anyone learn anything some of
them this the third or fourth time at
one of these programs if you do the math
that cost like twenty thousand dollars
per job gained and the job is more than
likely to be at a local McDonald's than
something else but it's played all over
the
is the organization that good jobs first
that did a pretty good review 314 state
economic developments that involves
subsidies since 1976 and over all of
those years the cash has just gone to
965 companies we're talking 110 billion
dollars warren buffett got a billion
Berkshire Hathaway Boeing of course they
got 13 billion through 131 different
subsidies sixteen thousand subsidies
went to Fortune 500 companies worth 63
billion dollars
I'm a free-market guy they don't need it
they don't need it big government
bailouts have been a part of our history
for some time and I think probably one
of the best cautionary tales in my mind
is a reconstruction Finance Corporation
Great Depression coming on they cobbled
together two billion dollars we've got
to do something about this I got to tell
you if you thought the jobs council was
pretty transparent this was the most
flagrant form favoritism and cronyism
imaginable if the first head of this
thing was the vice-president Charles
Dawes he they made him in charge of it
he quit because he had his bank in
Chicago he got a 90 million dollar bail
out the banks still went under the next
guy in charge of it he directed 12
million to the bank he owned in
Cleveland I mean it was just one
connection after another after another
and the shenanigans kept going
FDR comes in the Democrats get a chance
at the troughs and they go crazy just
like everyone else and newspapers are
bailed out and everyone's bailed out I
know here's the thing though guys at the
end of the day that this the money
doesn't come from thin air right we know
this you know it's not about the Federal
Reserve as the federal government has to
find ways to redistribute cash to their
crony partners and this is one of the
ways or one of the reasons so many
dreams so many hopes have been crushed
have been dashed on Main Street many
historians will say that the Great
Depression should have been a couple
years long huge mistakes were made huge
policies were made a lot of times to
protect big corporation it's not the
nation tariffs trade wars and excise tax
on gas and excise tax on on tires how
about an excise tax on telephone calls
oh let's raise the top tax rate 63
percent from 25 percent all of this the
worst combination of action that could
have possibly been done so what would
have been your normal panic of two three
years became the Great Depression and
it's really crazy because these are
still the solutions that are being sold
to the American public hey raise the top
tax rate except now at least you know
it's interesting now though they don't
sell it all the time as an economical
ixr more so it's just being fair it's
the right thing to do not saying it
would even they're not even bothering to
say it will fix the economy anymore it's
just say hey you jealous help us get the
money from these guys so then finally
the Great Depression ends and you would
think okay the RFC I guess whatever job
you were supposed to do it's over they
don't need you anymore and let's fall to
tent nah that didn't happen lasted all
the way through World War two finally it
was closed off by Eisenhower before
though he took a small schnitzel of it
and started this thing called the Small
Business Administration and I always say
to people good luck if you're a small
business trying to get an SBA loan and
you don't already have money its crony
capitalism on a smaller level and I
wanted to talk about Eisenhower in the
industrial military industrial complex
1961 the White House and Howard's really
his famous speech about the
military-industrial complex
it was his farewell speech and in many
ways it was very prescient they talked
about the power of computers he talked
about the rising cost of college and a
fundamental change of what college
education was all about but of course
the speech was focused on government
pumping money into the private military
industry and the inherent corruption
that will come from it
and enter rally cry you know for a lot
of people to this day one of the reasons
we should put crony capitalism to bed
now the speech is really fantastic and
really interesting one line that stood
out for me though is this one this
conjunction of an immense military
establishment and a large arms industry
is new in the American experience the
total influence economic political even
spiritual is felt in every city every
state house every office of the federal
government we recognize the imperative
need for this development yet we must
not fail to comprehend its grave
implications our toil resources and
livelihood are all involved so it is
very so is the very structure of our
society now maybe if you're a critic of
Eisenhower you would say ok well the
great highway project which might be the
crowning glory of his presidency was
indeed a military project it was
overseen by the Department of Defense I
would also say in his speech when he
sort of said well you know we don't need
to have these these military companies
because we can always take someone who
makes plowshares and they can make
swords that doesn't necessarily work
anymore either
but I will say there has been
out-and-out robbery of the Treasury in
the name of the military-industrial
complex giving an example earlier this
year next Sorento put out a great
diagram the cost of an OHA
Kiowa helicopters known as h1 is made by
Bell Helicopter the different parts that
are used on this thing in the markup
remember the mark-up we pay for the
smallest markup is 300% I just want to
read some of these to you the sleeve
spacer the market fair market price of
$7.49 the American taxpayer pays 30
bucks for it the shouldered shaft 1200
bucks we pay 5,800 bucks the wear sleeve
50 bucks and whenever you can get it we
paid 249 the fluid filter body 566 butts
we pay 2,900 for it the inner swash
plate cap and that's short what it cost
but wherever you can get it at a fair
market price it would be 412
we in this room though we paid 2,300
bucks for it
the pylon support 400 bucks
try 3600 guys 700 percent markup the
shim I'm not sure if they got these at
Ace Hardware but if they do it's only 25
bucks if you get it through this program
it's 237 bucks the sleeve busing the
straight head the straight head pin a
$36 item that we paid $500 for him
crown coupling and the highest 1/2 the
bevel gear normally 445 bucks the
American taxpayer paid $8,000 for it
a 1700 percent markup I happen to be a
serious fan of a strong military I think
what we're doing with manpower is
criminal and dangerous
we cannot gut the military but it can be
fixed
with some real smart cost-cutting
there's so many projects out there that
we don't need listen we've got 16 spy
agencies I I think they're cool I I'm
pretty sure every single day something
happens that saves our lives and we
don't know about doesn't happen with any
fanfare so I'm good with that but some
of the numbers out there some of these
weapons and the armament it's just
ridiculous I mean you have military
commanders who are saying we don't need
that but the bottom line is we have to
be honest about this is the kind of
bacon that most members of Congress
cannot afford to give up and expect to
be reelected so in that respect we all
have to ultimately look in the mirror
and say hey will we vote in the guy who
didn't bring us the bridge to nowhere
now with alarm 19 however who happened
to be a former five-star general was the
percentage of the government budget that
was spent on defense the numbers
actually we're interesting because they
went up under his presidency after the
war the RFC actually was we really got
that started but government spending the
defense part of government spending was
69 percent of all government spending in
1954
if fell steadily it's been gone up since
2000 we've been in a couple of wars
since then and it's a little over 20
percent again I don't have a problem
with the percentage
I do have a problem though with paying
someone 1700 percent markup for
something so let's talk about these
bailouts the modern-day bailouts because
like so many things in America they've
only gotten better 1970 we had Penn
Central Rail the Nixon administration
steps in with the Federal Reserve
Congress says we don't want to do it
they go bust Fed steps in any way puts
out money to the tune of about 3 billion
in 2008 dollars then there's Lockheed
which by the way I think reported
Tuesday great numbers but in 1971 they
were in trouble so we passed the
emergency loan guarantee Act one point
four billion dollars Franklin National
Bank in 1974 they lost 63 million
dollars so guess how much we stepped in
what to save them
1.7 billion huh figure out that math
okay New York City Ford says drop dead
then he says I was just kidding the New
York City seized on all financial act
two point three billion then equivalent
to nine billion dollars in today's money
Chrysler one right we got to start on
these Chrysler bailouts we got to start
numbering them now
Chrysler 1 1979 lost a billion bucks
they go hat in hand to the government
the government says hey this Lee Iacocca
it's a real cool dude game 1.5 billion
four billion in today's dollars
continental Illinois same thing
eighth largest bank they get in trouble
go belly-up nine point five billion
dollars the savings alone debacle that
was really really sort of the precursor
right that was like the real precursor
to the to the to saving the banks this
last time around almost 300 billion in
1989 the airline industry we understood
after September 11 people were afraid to
fly gas prices were going up they need a
help so we passed the air transportation
safety and stabilization act cost about
nineteen billion in today's dollars an
airline was so grateful they've risen
prizes ever since okay we have to pay
for everything pretty soon you gonna
take a roll of quarters on the plane if
you want to use the bathroom I mean
really it's I'm all eight I'm free
markets but we allowed them to
it was like they become a cowboy okay
you go from 10:00 to 5:00 Park half the
fleet charge them for everything stocks
have been phenomenal then we of course
fast forward to Bear Stearns 30 billion
Fannie Mae Freddie Mac AIG 85 billion
another auto industry bailout of course
Ford didn't participate in it General
Motors they participated in a big time
and of course we all know about I lost
track anyone know how many recalls
they've had this year and I mean really
I think there might be like three GM
cars that weren't recalled you know and
it's really bad because they were they
were selling some bad stuff and taking
our money at the same time they were
selling and ignoring some real bad
signals I wonder one day of the truth'll
that will come out about that who knew
what because I got a feeling the auto
industry knew and a government knew it's
just my gut feeling
Citigroup Bank of America all of these
things of course the big big bailout of
these banks that was in his spirit of
the RFC and I can remember every day
waking up and there was a new acronym
there was the term auction facility
there was a term securities lending
facility there was the primary dealer
credit facility there was the asset back
commercial paper there was the money
market mutual fund the quiddity facility
there was another commercial paper
funding facility then there was the
money market investor funding facility
then there was a term back asset-backed
securities loan facility like I think if
anyone in this room it's just written a
letter on the right letterhead and like
hey listen I'm a bank I need money you
would have got a check then of course
the mother of them all tarp October 3rd
2008 seven hundred billion dollars we're
gonna go in there we're gonna take care
of the auto industry two credit markets
AIG banking will set up the capital
purchase program the Community
Development Program the public-private
partnership the asset guarantee program
don't forget about housing hemp how
about making homes affordable
how about refinancing of
course you always have to go after the
executive compensation but tarp is one
of these things like the RFC that was
started and became so big and so amazing
with so few rules a Don King like
arrangement they can not put it to bed
Geithner said hey we can use that for
solar energy someone said we could yeah
he said where do you see it well where
don't you see it
all right give Solyndra the money nuts
it goes on they've got money dangled out
there right now all of this is always
done under the guise of helping the
little people of helping Main Street the
JOBS Act was passed very quietly great
name what's happened no jobs but when
Wall Street fell to step up to the plate
for the last election the way they did
the first time around
President Obama leaned real heavy on
Silicon Valley one big payback has been
as Jobs Act a record amount of IPOs this
year high tech IPOs companies that are
not ready to go public
hardly any scrutiny they've cut down all
the due diligence requirements every day
go public go public go public every time
they go public the VCS get paid the john
doors of the world make a whole lot of
money the Exim Bank listen I know the
Republicans are real afraid of not
winning the midterms I think it was
shameful that they continued to let this
Exim Bank go I really think that the
banner let everybody down I know they're
afraid I know they're walking on
eggshells but you got to show some
leadership that was gutless and they
talk about well it helps Main Street
give me a break
it helps minorities oh really well I'm
looking at something that said less than
1% of the exporters in this program are
minorities and they got less than 2% of
the cash it's all a giant gargantuan
piggy bank it's an incestuous
relationship and they
it just gets larger and larger the greed
has no bounds the power has no bounds so
the question is how do we fix it
obviously it wouldn't be easy to fix
it's been in place for a long time I
think it would take something like a
revolution something like what we saw in
Tunisia something like what we saw in
Cairo you guys know the story of the
Gordian knot the Gordian knot de
Freudians there's a group of people
called the fried jeans and they didn't
have a king so the Oracle said to the
people well the next person that comes
into town should be the king so a guy
named gordias comes into town on an ox
cart he's a year a king so he ruled
pretty well he had a Sunday - you might
have heard the story of - and he
dedicated a monument to his father and
it was ox cart tied in his really
intricate knot and for years in years
people trying to take that knot apart it
couldn't be done
the Gordian knot could not be taken
apart so legend has it that Alexander
the Great
finally was able to undo the knot but
before he could he had to cut it so he
could find the ends of the knot that was
the secret and somehow Americans have to
find a way to cut this rope how to cut
this Gordian knot that is Capitol crony
capitalism we've got to dump the Federal
Reserve we got to get out of the IMF in
a World Bank we got to close the
export-import bank we got to we got to
let these government-sponsored
enterprises become real businesses
closed down all of these temporary
programs limit our budgets stop
borrowing money get out of the student
loan program let the military be run by
generals and that civilians and
congressmen trying to win elections and
have term limits two-term senators
three-term congressman and that's it
that's it guys
we'll now have a brief period for
questions if you have a question raise
your hand and microphone will be brought
to you don't ask me about any stocks I'm
down on I'll deny it I'll pull the Jim
Cramer say I sold it yesterday Thank You
Charles I work for Raytheon in the
defense industry and I'm a Contracting
Manager I guess what I wanted to let you
know is that what I have seen and I've
worked but on both sides I've been in
the Navy working as a PCO for with
against General Electric I bought the
engines that were on the f-18 and now I
work on the other side at work in the
with Raytheon but what I have seen is
that part that you would buy commercial
off-the-shelf for 50 cents I get a spec
for that screw that is 25 pages long and
it requires me and my personnel my
engineers to buy to that spec that I
have a 50 dollar screw they are you know
what you you it's it's interesting you
you come across that that it's the
defense industry that's the issue it's
not what we have is a culture with me
within the Defense Department the
personnel there they cannot give any
money back they if they give any money
back and show that they have saved money
to their upper personnel they look
irrelevant so what you have is a culture
within the Defense Department they do
not give money back when I worked at at
the naval aviator or Naval Air Systems
Command in Crystal City and I came out
from Michigan State with my degree and I
saved a money and they looked at me and
said spend it I don't care what you buy
spend it yeah so I think you have a
culture that hog ties the defense
contracting that we are forced to buy to
the spec and if we we just need to have
the military begin real realistically
looking at what they are wanting to buy
and I think you could see a lot of
savings but isn't there also a revolving
door to so that these same military guys
and gals who are putting together these
specs when they leave they go and they
get a great job yeah it's it's and
that's a big large part of it they they
don't really have the incentive to to
make streamline this stuff but later on
they're gonna go and make a lot of money
and get their bonuses paid off of some
of this stuff thanks a lot really
appreciate it
Charles thank you again so much for
coming I just really appreciate having
here healthcare you didn't mention those
two words but I mean how do you navigate
your choices when you're looking at
buying opportunities when there's there
if you think military industrial complex
is crony capitalism the entire
healthcare system for decades has been
crony capitalism and Obamacare just put
it on steroids
again exponentially especially things
like we talked about the electronic
medical record system I'm sure even
though there weren't doctors or patients
at the Obamacare negotiating table the
electronic medical record companies were
there oh yeah and the insurance
companies were there absolutely I mean
from a stock market point of view is
pretty easy you know you investing in
players who were there because insurance
company is if they come up short guess
what there's a provision to make them
whole with our money for a few years and
that's gonna make it look like the
premiums are moving and they'll brag
about the fact that they're not moving
but when that provision goes away in two
or three years they're gonna skyrocket
like crazy it's gonna I mean I don't
know it's that's something that the
general public has to be aware up but
when Ezekiel Emanuel says he wishes he
would die at 75 first of all that's he's
lying okay you might be surprised to
find out that he lies occasionally the
chief architect of Obamacare but what he
did was he set us up for those panels
those death panels and it might sound
like a crude phrase but it's something
akin to that to your point I don't know
I wish I had the answer
I just I just hope the alarm gets
sounded I do look at polls for midterms
and it's interesting that now Obamacare
has fallen pretty dramatically in terms
of its importance and the Democrats are
actually doing better on Obamacare than
Republicans now the good news is that
people are more concerned about economy
jobs taxes foreign policy and things
like that so that's a message that's
going to probably have to get out there
through experience as some of these
things fall apart and people really
feeling in their own lives but I don't
think we should pound the message to
pound a message and then people will be
able to connect it in our lives when
they start to see whoa what happened and
some of these set asides and subsidies
go away but other than that I have no
clue it's just it's crazy health care in
this contributed so much and continue to
contribute independent of what their
ages are gonna be told sorry you don't
get that chemotherapy sorry you don't
get that open-heart surgery so you don't
get that medical implant and it's
because of your age and of course you're
right exec you exempt himself you know
socialism is for the people not for the
socialist yeah the rich socialists
although that could be redundant in his
case logic is that new bombs then come
into office so do you have any
suggestions for institutional changes
well we can prevent this sort of
behavior in the future there was a movie
a long time ago I think in the early 70s
called bananas or going bananas a Woody
Allen movie anybody see that movie and
bananas that there was this guy as a
third world country and he helped to
facilitate he led the revolution and his
heart was in the right place he wanted
to help the people because delivered
they were being treated like garbage but
when he got in there the power was so
immense that it took over him see in my
mind they don't go in his bums but once
they get that power and they don't want
to let it go that's when they become
bummed so I don't have a problem with
throwing the bums out
I don't think people really
honest-to-goodness non-politicians to go
in there will be bumps but if they can
stay there for 30 40 years the more
they're in there the more they become
bums the more they this power corrupts
them so that's for me is what would
negate what they're saying you know I
don't think that we there are a lot of
people I think a lot of people go in
there with the greatest of intentions
but once you're in there you have to
play the game if you want to stay how
many people are going to go back to
their constituents and say guys
everything I had a chance to bid on for
our community would have been wrong to
the American taxpayer are you nuts
you want to see a scene of someone
running from a town hall meeting with
getting hit in the head with signs and
tomatoes but that's my that's just where
I think I just think that the power
itself and the desire never to leave is
what turns them into bumps so so based
on what you just said I think I already
know the answer but have you ever
considered for running for office I have
in the past yeah but I always tell
people I think I've been a little bit
too human in my life so if they if they
went back to Romney having problems when
he was in elementary school I don't even
want to do I wouldn't ever want to deal
with it just a little bit too human if I
could cut out maybe a 15-year swath
there but since the internet I'm I'll
just talk from the sidelines but I
appreciate it Charles Peter Schiff uses
one of my favorite terms when he talks
about QE infinity with respect to the
Fed and I'm wondering what your take is
on market growth in the more than
doubling since 2009 on the market bottom
how much of that has been driven by kind
of monopoly money as opposed to
legitimate sustainable growth I don't
think as much as Peter Schiff does one
thing I think that's been first of all I
always find an interesting when we
discuss the market where people pick
like their starting point like for
instance when people say how much the
markets up or how much someone's
performed for the air I think that's the
dumbest thing we talk about in the
market as if on December 29th we sell
everything and we
all start from scratch on January 1st
you know but if you say 2009 we were at
the dowels at 6600
so if that's your fair value point then
this move would look absurd but we're
only up 22% from from the top back in
2001 13 14 years ago that does not look
so absurd that's a couple percent a year
I think one of the things that drove it
was for me when I start my analysis at
the market in economics I start with the
global economy and before I even start
with that I start with global peace I
think the and even though things look
bad if you think about the last few
years and what's happened around the
world global peace enabling global
prosperity and extra billion people in
the and and in the middle class and
Harley reported their numbers this week
sales in China of Harley Davidsons are
at like 26 27 percent you know they love
Whirlpool washing machines in Argentina
and Brazil so it manipulates it and it's
designed to manipulate the market it's
designed to make it the only attractive
thing out there but there's been some
other features and this is why a lot of
people who look out their window can't
they say there's no way the market is up
because when I look out my window I see
the spare but they don't see the
building boom they don't see Azerbaijan
they don't see the building boom in
Panama City they don't see what's going
on around the world and places that when
we when I do think about it in their
minds it's a dirt road but it's not
pretty soon the New York City skyline is
going to be like puny it's like people
will come to this country and giggle
when they look at it like that's your
skyline nothing two miles high so
there's no doubt I don't know what
percentage it is I don't think it's as
much as Peter does I am I am I will I
don't lie what's the Fed didn't exist I
don't see where the Fed has done any
good for anyone except create a lot of
danger and you know with that with their
balance sheet now I think of four
trillion dollars so we contribute
something like 20% to the IMF and the
World Bank
so if you're talking about you know
infrastructure in Panama you could be
talking about 20% of everyone in this
room's dollars essentially funding the
same type of mechanism so I guess that's
where the rubber meets the road is how
much of global economic growth is
attributed to ECB or Fed or World Bank
etc and you know it's hard to put a
finger on it obviously low rates have
helped there's no doubt just like low
rates will help someone like an Apple
sitting on all the money in the world
still borrow money to buy back their
stock yeah so I mean there's no doubt
that there's ways of taking advantage of
these low rates that have helped juice
the market I just don't know to what
degree but also there's a whole lot of
money out there that has been seeking
opportunities and a lot of those
opportunities from even from private
money you know if you look at foreign
direct investment and those trends have
been mind-boggling in places that 15
years ago wouldn't have existed at all
so like I said I'm less than Peter I
know the plays are all I just don't know
to what the greeting good evening
Charles I run a think-tank in Idaho a
very red state which is very big on
corporate welfare and when I talk to
policymakers about this they say well
we're in the middle of a sort of a war
with other states they see the ads on
Fox News with you know startup New York
and I'm wondering if you have some
suggestions or ideas on this phenomenon
we're seeing where states are competing
against one another and they're offering
these incentives which are really just
killing the economy and killing small
businessman well I think of some of
these things like a New York State again
it gets back to the idea of you you
lower the business but you crush the
people who work there because they're
gonna make the money up somewhere and
and and it's so funny because the last
question about money printing you know
abenomics in japan and they're like well
what's going on how come it's not
working it's kind of weird that they
would have lower rates and also raise
taxes at the same time and wonder why
consumers aren't spending you know if
these the New York's and New Jersey's
the California's of the world they're
the worst examples of income inequality
even though they talked to talk
and this route that they're going is so
misleading and it gets back to these
local subsidiaries going to a handful of
companies that create a few jobs so it's
it's the people I think the people have
to learn I have to understand what's
really going on and at the end of the
day that they're actually the ones who
pay for this the money comes from
somewhere and it's coming out of your
pocket and until the people become
educated enough to revolt against it I
think it's going to continue to go on
alright guys thank thank you very much I
really appreciate it
thanks so much
Thank You Charles that was tremendous in
so much information thank you very much
that's a great wrap up to the main part
of our free market forum for those of
you who are driving home tonight please
have a safe trip thank you for coming I
would remind the faculty members are 150
faculty members that we have a faculty
session in the morning at 8 o'clock and
for those of you who are other guests
and staying here at the hotel we are
will have buffet breakfast again in the
morning starting at 6:30 so please help
yourself please take the flowers on the
table and have a great night thank you
you